uh matt gates it's almost like every day
there's a new scandal facing
beleaguered republican congressman matt
gates earlier this week
we told you about his apparent
involvement in
running a shill candidate in florida's
ninth district i won't retell the entire
story but you can check it out
on our youtube channel or the podcast
from earlier this week i think it was
monday or tuesday where we covered that
we also know that he is being looked at
for involvement in child sex
trafficking and a whole bunch of other
things the fbi or federal authorities
rather
seized his iphone some time ago it's
looking really really bad for matt gates
republican congressman steve scalise who
is a horrible person
says that if indeed
matt gates is charged if there are
charges levied against him that
they would take action and remove
him from his committee assignments if
the department of justice
files charges according to newsweek
scalise added that historically
lawmakers who face charges
have been removed from committee
assignments immediately as a precedent
this is the same this mirrors the house
republican rules
that lawmakers indicted for felonies and
sentenced to at least two years in
prison must resign now the weird thing
about sentenced to two years in prison
is
their terms are only two years long so
that
it sort of seems a little strange that
you you have to resign
from committees uh but i guess you could
be sentenced and get a suspended
sentence or something like that i don't
know scalise going on to say it's hard
to speculate on rumors but if something
really formal happened from justice
we would of course react and take action
scalise says he has not spoken with matt
gates
and has not heard matt gates explanation
for the allegations
but imagines he will be speaking with
him this week
saying quote it's serious things alleged
obviously we will want to get the facts
gates continues to deny the allegations
um although the denials often also
include raising the alarm with
additional
derogatory information for example when
he first went on tucker carlson's
show to deny some
element of the allegations he also said
i've never paid anyone for sex which at
the time was not even part of what we
thought was going on
increasingly it seems matt gates
actually has paid people for sex and
whatever your thoughts are
uh about paying people for sex the
boneheadedness of
matt gates raising new issues that
weren't even
yet being looked at it's odd to say the
least
gates did not go to a weekly meeting of
house republicans
yesterday according to steve scalise and
it seems as though increasingly many
republicans i mean like it seems like
marjorie taylor green is sort of
sticking with them she may go down with
the ship
um it seems as though you know some of
the wackier members
are sticking with matt gates but
increasingly lots of people are
are abandoning him it may indeed be a
ship that simply goes down now as far as
judiciary
there's a kind of weird i don't know if
i'd call it
i guess it is a conflict of interest
because matt gates is currently on
the judiciary committee the house
judiciary committee
has oversight power over the very
department of justice
that would be indicting matt gates it's
not
as though there's a very clear way in
which he's going to be able to do
x or y as it relates to the
investigation against him
but steve scalise saying well he'll have
to resign from the committees if there
are charges
and one of the committees he's on does
oversight of the entity that would be
charging him
that's you know that that's certainly a
question mark
and then lastly you know steve scalise
as i mentioned is a horrible person
he really can't be trusted so there's a
question of whether they will actually
do it it's clearly
in the house rules scalise is saying
republicans would demand
that he do it um i wouldn't be shocked
if gates does get charged and the house
controlled by democrats based on the
rules moves forward
with stripping gates of his committee
assignments i wouldn't be shocked if
some republicans pulled out the
allegations alone or not evidence and
this isn't what should happen even
though these are the house rules
we'll wait and see i'm increasingly of
the mindset that there's probably some
kind of charge coming against matt gates
but uh without a doubt he is innocent
until proven guilty and he has not yet
even been charged so we have to allow
the investigations to be carried out one
of our sponsors today is strategic
voters a new podcast that features
election experts
political campaign strategists and
everyday americans
who sit down and discuss the biggest
issues in the u.s political landscape
on the activism side strategic voters as
an organization
aims to encourage people to vote with
the benefit of the country
as a whole in mind instead of just
voting one party
down the ballot if you want to hear some
really different
and interesting opinions and approaches
to voting and viewing policies
give the strategic voters podcast a
listen
the latest two episodes feature rachel
cobb and lana atkinson as guests i've
been listening to it myself
i've been really enjoying it it's very
grassroots and
independent which i love find the
strategic voters podcast
on all major podcast platforms and make
sure to follow them on twitter
at strategic voters